[Music]
hey chicken lovers George Camel here
with another minute money hack today's
hack is a saucy one which by the way did
you know that chick-fil-a sauce is just
a magical blend of their honey mustard
ranch and barbecue sauces
who knew sorry I get easily distracted
by sauces anyways as you probably
guessed today we're hacking one of my
favorite establishments chick-fil-a
let's do this sometimes you'll find a
survey on your receipt don't throw it
away take two minutes to fill it out for
a free sandwich plus they actually read
this stuff order ahead with the app to
avoid those lunchtime lines at the
double drive-thru and make sure to scan
your app when ordering in person to earn
free treats of your choice by the cow
calendar in store every December for
around 8 bucks
swipe the attached card once a month to
get a featured menu item for free and
hey quality high-rez pics of cows at
everybody
cow Appreciation Day happens every year
in July show up in a cow costume and get
a free entree of your choice want a
cheap meal the kids menu has smaller
portions and lower prices plus you can
trade in your toy for a medium fryer
drink upgrade or a free ice cream
[Music]
Google chick-fil-a secret menu and thank
me later
my favorite order your fries well done
for a crunch heard around the world my
second favorite oh wait I'm running out
of time it's and there's your minute
money hack
[Music]